popular homeless shelter and drug deal
parking lot Burger King has a new
marketing campaign the home of the
whopper no longer boasts about its
bigger beef the bigger the burger of the
bed Roberta the burgers burger at Burger
King no now the fast-food giant is
relying on leftist politics to sell
hamburgers we'll analyze their latest ad
and what it means for the culture then
Benjie backer tries to convince me that
conservatives should care about the
environment
finally Jacob Airy joins the panel of
deplorable to talk about that sexual
deviant barny the dinosaur illegal
aliens screaming at Chuck Schumer and
for some reason not being arrested and
deported and why half the country wants
to investigate the FBI
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
before we get into Burger King and the
culture get ready on Tuesday January
30th our president will speak to the
nation in his second State of the Union
address a very exciting event and you
should watch it with us here at the
Daily wire it starts at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific we will be
hanging out with you for the whole time
leading up to during and after the
address will be there for every wild
hand gesture every off teleprompter
remark and of course the hilarious and
ridiculous rebuttal from Democrats catch
live streams at daily wire comm daily
wire Facebook or daily wire YouTube to
spend the evening with Ben drew Clavin
daily wire god-king jeremy boring and me
as we comment on the address and
relentlessly mock our government and our
political leaders will also be joined by
special guests at various points in the
evening so tune in to find out who will
drop by again that's next Tuesday
January 30th 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m.
Pacific
follow us on Facebook and YouTube and
get notified when we go live so we can
spend every absolutely forgettable
moment together it's a party you will
not want to miss ok and look guys I want
to get into this but first before I can
look at that shave look at that my shave
here and I don't need I rarely even use
shaving cream I just kind of I walk out
of the shower my Zoar have closed I
haven't a coffee at work of FA yet so I
just kind of go boom boom boom boom boom
but the reason that I don't rip up my
entire face and have you know blood
everywhere is because of Dollar Shave
Club you have heard me talk about the
amazing shape that I get from Dollar
Shave Club especially when I use their
dr. Carver's shave butter this shaved
butter I don't really know how to
describe it it's not like a one of those
big shaving creams and it's not like
that gel which is not for cool guys to
say the lead on once that gel it's a
millennial they want the shave butter it
is really really good I'm here to tell
you that I'm never gonna give up that
membership I'm actually adding more
Dollar Shave Club products to my daily
routine so Dollar Shave Club makes
products for your hair and your face
your skin your shower everything and
it's all really good stuff you know one
aspect of doing this show is I never get
paid
anything I don't get a salary or you
know really anything sometimes they'll
give me an extra fluffy cardboard box to
sleep in on the sidewalk outside of the
studio but one advantage is that I'll
occasionally get some freebies from
sponsors this Dollar Shave Club stuff is
so good it is the best razor I've ever
used they use only the finest premium
ingredients and they deliver it to you
just like they do to your to your razors
so you know this means no more annoying
trips to the store in the old days I
would use the same razor blade for about
27 or 28 years in a row so this you
don't need that anymore you just go you
know order it it's very modern very 21st
century you pay a low rate every month
they'll send everything right to your
door you don't have to cruise up and
down the aisle looking you know up at
the shelves and figuring out where
everything is they have everything
razors body cleanser hair gel and how do
I put this you know in Europe they
they'll have a bidet when when you're
having a little alone time you're
digesting your meal and it'll have a
little bit day to be a little cleaner
about that in America we don't usually
do that but they have wipes
such that you can achieve the same
effect so do that Dollar Shave Club has
you covered head to toe now is a great
time to try it you will get your first
month of their best razor along with
Scrabble sized versions of shave butter
body cleanser and yes that extra-special
European jolt for your derriere for just
five dollars after that replacement
cartridges ship for just a few bucks a
month
it is the DSC starter set okay yours
today for just five bucks that is a
basically free go do it get it
exclusively at dollarshaveclub.com
slash qoph fa COV fe fe
dollarshaveclub.com slash cough fa c OV
e fe fe what is it Marshall slash
khofifah okay let's get right into this
today I want to talk about politics
infecting every aspect of our culture
what it says about the millennial
generation what it says about our
culture what it says about the new slew
of woe corporations here is Burger
King's latest hamburger ad
got a number one
number 98
you got the Walker yeah so you got the
slow axis whopper pass it's on it's on
the menu right there at the fast medium
and slow slow Mbps fast Mbps or hyper
fast Mbps Mbps of course standing for
making burgers per second well that's
that's how you get a pass it's the
highest priority this is like a
latencies so me like 15 yeah fast lane
slow lane it's like maybe like 15 20
minutes what are you talking about
I reckon Corporation believes that they
can sell more and make more money
selling with chicken sandwiches and
chicken fries and now they're slowing
down the access to the wok that will you
give it an option of chicken sandwich or
I don't want a chicken Walker you get
the point right you'd use it isn't that
clever isn't that isn't that clever and
that's how they're by the way they
wouldn't make any more money doing this
they'd go out of business they are
trying to make more money though that's
why they have this ad what sort of
strange about this hamburger ad you'll
notice is that it doesn't at any point
try to sell hamburgers instead it sells
smug lib attitudes toward political
issues that have nothing whatsoever to
do with its business or its product or
really even its customers it's trying to
use government regulation of the
internet so-called net neutrality to
make hamburgers more appealing that is
horrifying this is what Burger King ads
used to look like in the good old days
the vanishing American the vanishing
American hamburger it's been getting
smaller and smaller and smaller
well Burger King is out to save the
hamburger with the whopper a hamburger
so big it takes an extra big toasted bun
just to hold it and we top that with
pickles and chopped onions and fresh
tomatoes and crisp lettuce the whopper
the king-sized burger you only get at
Burger King
groovy take the drive to Burger King
home of the whopper the burgers are
bigger at Burger King
[Music]
the bigger the burger the better the
burger the burgers are bigger at Burger
King this that ad was so effective
because it actually sold hamburgers that
I'd was so effective that I was born 20
years after that ad played and I know it
I know how I remember it I think a lot
of people remember it too but these days
they don't talk about you know the
vanishing American and you have a an
American Indian looking all perplexed at
the tiny little hamburger patty these
days his advertisements instead prattle
on about obscure federal regulations of
course Burger King does not actually
care about net neutrality that didn't
make any public statement in 2015 when
the FCC imposed rules to regulate the
Internet
Burger King does not currently lobby for
government regulation of the Internet on
Capitol Hill or at the FCC CMO of Burger
King Fernando Machado said we believe
the internet should be like Burger King
restaurants a place that doesn't
prioritize and welcomes everyone that is
why we created this experiment to call
attention to the potential effects of
net neutrality that is a true they did
it to call attention to their hamburgers
there was exactly the opposite of what
he just said but it worked
the mainstream media loved it the verge
had a headline Burger King made a
surprisingly good ad about net
neutrality Reuters Burger King tweaks us
regulator in new net neutrality
advertisement entrepreneur you want
fries with that Burger King explains net
neutrality in less than three minutes
Fast Company Burger King uses the
whopper to teach a valuable lesson on
net neutrality marketing land Burger
King whopper spleen the net neutrality
is a repeal in new ad ad week
Burger King deviously explains net
neutrality by making people wait longer
for whoppers the thing is it didn't
deviously net explained that neutrality
the explanation had all the subtlety of
a hand grenade or a trump tweet but I
repeat myself it was not devious what it
did deviously was pretend to add
vegetate for net neutrality first of all
the analogy is total nonsense
the not a lot of people did a whole
episode on net neutrality not so a lot
of people still don't understand it
there was an incredible infographic sent
around
a Democrat candidate for Senate ROH
Khanna a pro Net Neutrality Democrat
running for Congress from Silicon Valley
this tells the whole story so last
November ROH Khanna this Democrat for
Ana neutrality in the heart of tech land
posted an infographic on the internet
comparing the cost of the internet with
government regulations commonly called
net neutrality and without government
regulations no net neutrality with the
regulations he showed you could get
video email gaming and social media all
for one price fifty $4.99 per month
without the regulations he warned voters
you would have to pay different prices
for each so that could be $17.99 per
month for video $8.99 a month for email
$14.99 for gaming $12.99 for social
media and you could opt out of certain
platforms and pay a little bit less so
maybe you only pay for Netflix video but
not YouTube video so it'd be cheaper
than all the videos so on and so forth
the trouble with Roe Connors argument
here is that the net neutrality version
without the customer choice cost fifty
$4.99 a month and the no net neutrality
version the deregulated joy one cost 54
ninety-six a month so it's actually
three cents cheaper
he made the exact opposite point that he
was trying to make you know the argument
for government regulation of the
internet made the case against a
government regulation of the Internet
not very smart Roe Conniff so you'll
notice by the way that I'm stumbling on
my words a little bit here that I keep
saying government regulation of the
internet instead of net neutrality
that's because net neutrality is a
meaningless euphemism that is bandied
about by the left to sugarcoat the
reality of it which is giving the
government more control over the
internet making the internet less free
taking away consumer choice both as to
how they use the internet and as to how
they pay for the Internet but this is
what the left always does they rely on
these euphemisms these subtle little
lies that most people think are not
worth fighting about so they just use
them and in so doing that they can see
the whole premises so I'm not going to
do that it's tedious to use precise
language but it's also the most
effective way to shut down their
ridiculous arguments say Lobby that's
how it goes anyway back to net
neutrality why is a fast-food burger
company suddenly agitating
behalf of rules governing consumer
choice on the internet a month and a
half after the regulations were repealed
and two and a half years after the rules
were instituted to begin with a
fast-food burger company which has
nothing whatsoever to do with the issue
of internet regulation it's because of a
sad and tedious fact about our culture
this stunt from Burger King was exactly
that right it was a marketing gimmick
and it was geared toward a specific
demographic Millennials for years
Millennials have been turning away from
fast food leaving chains like Burger
King or McDonald's or whatever
scrambling according to a 2014 survey by
brand keys baby boomers are reporting an
18 percent drop in fast-food visits and
an 11 percent drop among Gen Xers the
worst news is from Millennials
Millennials are expected to replace baby
boomers as the nation's largest consumer
buying group within just two years by
2020 and Millennials hate fast food I
don't I love fast food it's one of my
guilty pleasures also stogies and booze
and fatty Italian meats and yeah yada
yada yada also fast food I really like
it that said most of my fellow
Millennials hate it according to the
2014 survey eighty nine percent of
Millennials prefer fast casual chains
like Chipotle even if those places cost
more which is absolutely insane
Arby's Wendy's McDonald's are about
seven million times better than Chipotle
or whatever
frou-frou rice and beans pho sophistic
and Millennials are willing to pay for
they also they don't give you a bola do
you remember they didn't Chipotle give
everybody bola a few years ago or you
coli or some of them one of those things
yeah so fast casual places like Chipotle
usually aren't even more expensive than
fast-food places it's the same thing you
see this you see the same thing on the
coasts and in the country it's the
people who prefer Dunkin Donuts just
Starbucks because Starbucks is
supposedly too fancy or expensive and
Dunkin Donuts that's for the Americans
oh but the two places cost the same
amount of money actually so Starbucks
just make stronger coffee and it has you
know twelve year olds drinking
milkshakes and and a bunch of wannabe
screenwriters on laptops and stuff
Dunkin Donuts has more construction
workers and donuts some things they cost
the same so Robert passuk off the
founder and president of brand keys
which did that survey he agrees that the
price
doesn't actually matter he explains you
don't build brands or loyalty on the
basis of price that only works for
commodities so facing an existential
threat from Millennials not eating in
their restaurants not able to manipulate
them on the basis of price really even
food you know it's gonna take a lot to
turn a place that has boasted for 50
years the bigger the burger the better
the burger the burger is bigger at
Burger King into some artisanal bespoke
salad restaurant so they try to make
they tried to make the King look like a
Brooklyn hipster with the big beard and
the the jewelry and the curls and
everything I'm not sure that worked
either so they have one tool at their
disposal that sadly says a lot about our
culture and in particular the culture of
Millennials they convert you signal and
slogan Iran politics sociologist Richard
Florida explained advertisers used to
wonder how a spot would play in Peoria
now they wonder how it'll play in
Brooklyn Rob Bayaka a creative executive
at a major ad agency he admitted the
same thing marketers are increasingly
relying on woke issue ads to target
Millennials in a phrase he says
creatives are trying to make their
toilet paper save the world even though
sometimes a Pringle is just a Pringle
but for Millennials a Pringle can never
just be a Pringle everything has become
politicized and activists obviously
mainstream journalism that was the first
to go the universities now even the NFL
even Pepsi even Burger King it's a sad
state of affairs it says a lot about our
culture's CS Lewis put it well he said a
sick society must think much about
politics as a sick man must think about
his digestion to ignore the subject may
be fatal cowardice for one as for the
other but if either comes to regard it
as the natural food of the mind if
either forgets that we think of such
things only in order to be able to think
of something else
then what was undertaken for the sake of
health has become itself a new and
deadly disease our society is without
question sick and so we have to think a
lot about politics but we're only
thinking about politics so that we can
think about culture and art and
philosophy and building things and
eternal questions and our nature and our
Creator among other things but
advertisers have rightly determined that
Millennials are obsessed with politics
shallow politics of that not as a means
but as an end and I think I think it's
because they're using politics as a
stand-in for something else they're
they're trying to place all of their
identity and all of their hopes and
politics
st. Augustine wrote about this he said
you have made us for yourself and our
hearts are restless until they find
their rest in thee O Lord
Pascal put it in other words there was
once in man a true happiness of which
all that now remains is the empty print
and trace this he tries in vain to fill
with everything around him seeking in
things that are not there the help he
cannot find in those that are though
none can help
since this infinite abyss can be filled
only with an infinite and immutable
object in other words by God himself
speaking of false religion and
millennial obsessions we have to bring
on Benji to talk about environmentalism
but before we bring Benji on we have to
talk about my food war that's what we
got to talk about my bedding baby that's
what we got to get to because we have a
new advertiser we have Boland branch
sheets this I told you look I probably
got more value in my Boland branch
sheets than I will ever be paid by Ben
or The Daily wire these sheets are so
nice
I just tried them out you know I've told
you for a long time now my fiance and I
have different opinions about bedding
I prefer beds there were a little firm
and sheets that are nice and soft and
sweet little ELISA prefers beds that I'm
not in but she does like these bow and
branch sheets so we're never going to
agree on anything but we could all use
more sleep some some nights I'll only
get 12 or 13 hours of sleep not my wreck
was at 16 and Boleyn branch sheets are
helping me to correct that getting a
great night's sleep is easier and more
affordable than you think you don't need
a new expensive mattress or sleeping
pills I you just need to change your
sheets and that's why you got to check
out Boleyn branch so everything Boleyn
branch makes from bedding to blankets is
made from 100% pure organic cotton which
means they start out super soft and they
get even softer over time
for bolin branch i would only buy
bedding that was in like the discount
rack on the side of the highway
i and i would just buy the cheapest
sheets i ever possibly could and these i
I never understood why you would buy
expensive sheets now I do I'm totally a
believer and Bolin branch will give you
a great deal on it so you buy directly
from Bolin branch so you're basically
paying wholesale prices luxury sheets
I've learned as I do my wedding registry
can cost up to a thousand dollars in the
store you can pay a thousand dollars on
sheets but Bolin bran cheats are only a
couple hundred bucks for the same
quality so everyone who tries Bolin
branch sheets loves them that's why they
have thousands of five-star reviews
Forbes The Wall Street Journal Fast
Company are all talking about Bolin
branch even three u.s. presidents sleep
on Bolin branch sheets three u.s.
presidents and one presidential endorsed
best-selling blank book author sleep on
Bolin bran sheets that's that's for or
somebody's that's for you know some some
four rows of a certain kind of people
shipping is free you can try them for 30
nights if you don't love them send them
back for a refund there is no risk here
but you were not gonna want to send them
back I assure you there is no risk
there's no reason not to give them a try
and you can say that you slept on the
same sheets as a bunch of presidents
hopefully not hopefully not bill I don't
know if let's I'll do some research into
that but three US presidents that's got
to be good quality to get started right
now my listeners get $50 off your first
set of sheets at bowl and branch calm
promo code Michael that is $50 off
that's a that is a good deal you got to
go do that right now Boleyn branch calm
promo code Michael mi CH AE L go to
Bowman branch calm today $50 off your
first set of sheets Bo LL and branch
calm promo code what's the promo code
Marshall Michael Michael promo code
Michael okay let's bring on Benjy Benjy
backer is the founder of the American
conservative coalition he has been a
conservative activist I think since he
was in the womb and he is a wonderful
college kid and but he's going to try to
convince me that conservatives should
care about the environment he's spoken
at CPAC I'm sure you've seen him
elsewhere as well
Benjy let's get right into it why should
conservatives care about the environment
Michael great to be
there's a few reasons first of all it
has an immense economic impact if the
environments doing well the economy is
doing well and that's just the truth
another reason for conservatives to
really care about the environment is
that it's the number one issue that
Millennials think about when they go to
the voting booth some polls showed it as
number two but either way it's it's a
really important issue for the youth
demographic when they go to the polls
and the truth of matter is Republicans
haven't done an amazing job making it a
priority over the past 10 or 15 years
and why is it by the way but I'm sure
before we go on because I agree with you
I see that talking to Millennials they
really care about the environment and
they're always worried about global
warming and things like that why why is
this the number one issue for
Millennials does that reflect some kind
of agenda in our schooling or is there
some more legitimate reason as to why
we're so concerned about it yeah I think
part of it is in the schooling obviously
we get taught about climate change and
other environmental issues from a young
age that being said I just think that
young people have an inclination to
change environmental policy because they
can see environmental changes happening
no matter if that's caused by man-made
climate change or not they see that
environmental changes have benefits if
it's done the right way and they also
know about the economic impacts of being
Pro environmental especially if you're
conservative who knows environmental
policy you know that being Pro
environmental can have immense economic
benefits and so I think that all those
together have canta made it a priority
you know obviously the the the schools
have pushed climate change into a lot of
people's minds and so that's probably
the first and foremost but there are
other reasons as well absolutely and do
you see any distinction here because I
do think these schools have kind of made
radicals out of conservatives like me
where all I want to do is throw those
little six-pack can plastic things on to
schools of dolphins because of of how
ridiculous the left is with its pro
environmental agenda do you see a
distinction between environmentalism and
conservationism I do and I think that
they should be the same thing I just
think that the left has pushed it so far
to the left that people have gotten
turned off by the environment and as a
result conservatives have kind of
dropped the subject and so I think both
sides are at fault that it's gone so far
to the left and we've gotten to this
huge divide where the right you know
goes so far to say okay let's drill on
national parks let's you know not even
care about the environment at all and
then the left has gone as far to say
you're you have to bike to work
otherwise the world's gonna blow up
obviously that's an exaggeration but
that's kind of how it seems sometimes
with the left and so what we try to do
at the American conservation coalition
is put it more in the middle where you
talk about some of the economic impacts
you talk about some of the you know
things that private people can do
probably businesses can do local
governments can do it's not all big
government and I think big government
has turned away a lot of conservatives
as well it's just been turned into this
thing where you expect the government to
handle every environmental problem
that's not how it used to be your
Republicans used to embrace these things
on a local level sure there used to be I
think before the environmental
conversation became so hysterical with
Al Gore suggesting that if we don't do
exactly what he wants the world is going
to end and then the world doesn't end
and he has even less credibility before
that conservatives were more open to it
but the distinction I see between
conservationism and environmentalism is
that environmentalism posits that little
animals and deer somehow have rights
that need to be protected they have the
right to not be shot or the right - I
don't know free health care or something
and conservationism says that we have to
preserve the animals so that we can keep
on shooting them but yeah you know
basically that we need to conserve our
natural environments because it's very
beautiful and we enjoy seeing these nice
animals and looking at beautiful parks
and but but for the conservationists it
seems to me it's all about the human the
human is ultimately what matters in this
relationship between the human and the
environment and for the
environmentalists I wonder if it's a
sort of pagan worshipping of an
environment a kind of anti-humanist
point of view that puts the little delta
smelt in
above human beings for some reason we
pour a huge percentage of our freshwater
to feed these little anchovies in
California rather than using them to
water golf courses so that we can you
know have a better time on the weekends
or something is there any is there
anything in in that messaging where you
think the environmental movement could
get a little bit more focused on human
beings and a little less concerned about
sardines
yeah actually so the first thing I'll
say is that I think everything is
related you know if you look at the
study of science or just the environment
in general everything has an effect on
one another but the fact that matter is
that conservationists are the best
environmental stewards out there if it
wasn't for hunters and fishers we'd have
overpopulation the life cycle wouldn't
happen between all the different animals
and plants and so when the environmental
left goes after hunters and fishers they
just don't realize that their imperative
and so vital to keeping our environment
going it's a matter of understanding the
life process and how that's all has they
all have to work together it's not just
punishing humans there needs to be a
cycle that goes around and I think that
the environmental left needs to realize
that on the right people need to realize
that at the same time animals plants
places of land those all matter as well
and if you do it the right way which
conservationists tend to do hunters and
fishers tend to be conservatives and
really care about the environment it can
have immense economic benefits and you
look at hunting and fishing and how much
it adds the US economy you look at clean
energy and how much that adds to the US
economy of jobs and revenue I mean
there's so many ways to reap the
benefits of these positive environmental
impacts how do you think the Trump
administration is doing on environmental
matters we've loved seeing Scott Pruett
deregulating deer a you know firing I
think half of the EPA not so much for
whatever impact that would have on the
environment we haven't seen much of one
but because he's slashing these awful
bureaucrats who think that they can run
our lives better than we can does Trump
get a passing grade so far from green
conservatives like you guys or does he
you have work to do I think he has a
little bit of work to do the
administration itself actually has been
pretty good in my opinion there's been a
lot of good things that have been
Ryan Zink he just did a hunting and
shooting sports Conservation Council
which is very imperative to to the
future environmental success of the
country actually Congress a lot of
Republicans have put forward some really
good legislation to help the backlog the
national parks for funding they put
together a few acts as well Rex
Tillerson has actually done some good
things as well on the environment
there's 33 Republicans on the climate
solutions caucus who kind of basically
say that it needs to be a priority those
are Congress men and women from all
walks of the conservative aisle so I
think that's really key I think Donald
Trump needs to make it a focus of his to
focus on the environment otherwise one
he's not gonna be able to get the youth
vote as easily in 2020 but additionally
I think that with him as president
conservatives have an opportunity to
show that it's not big government that
can solve these problems it's you know
private businesses it's local areas it's
state governments and local governments
and just citizens in general that can do
the right thing so making it a priority
I think it's gonna be important for him
and I think that it'll be something that
conservatives can kind of prove that
they can lead on if he makes it a
priority and that's such a nice point at
the end if the environmentalists left or
more likely the conservationists right
made the point that we need to protect
our environment ourselves at a very
local level I'm starting with the man in
the mirror I'm asking him to make a
change and municipal governments local
governments private organizations
conservation organizations or
corporations that would be a much easier
way to do it that'd be a much easier way
to build consensus on the issue rather
than saying we're gonna staff up some
crazy federal bureaucracy sign on to
absurd international agreements take
more of your tax money fund more private
jets to Brussels or Davos or whatever
whatever Al Gore thinks he's gonna do to
save the world this time if it became a
little bit more focused on a local level
and on how it relates to your own life I
think it's a great way to build
consensus on it and I wish you luck on
that
anything that will shut up al gore and
get him out of the room is good for me
Benjy will you stick around for the
panel can you stick around another maybe
15 minutes sure right I love it we have
got to bring on our panel to talk about
some news and by our panel I mean our
Jacob or Jacob Harry will join us but
before that listen Marshall is a tyrant
you know this he's a sadist and a tyrant
we have so much to talk about we've got
Barney the Dinosaur a running tantric
sex ring we've got a dog about illegal
aliens and we've got to talk about
investigating the FBI but if you're on
Facebook or YouTube
I'm sorry buster you got to go over to
Daley wire.com if you're already there
thank you very much you keep the lights
on you keep qoph fa in my cup you keep
my bedding very nice with Boleyn branch
sheets but if you don't go over there
already you've got to do it what will
you get well you'll get me you'll get
the intro Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you'll get to ask questions
for the conversation I think I'm up next
for that one so you can do that ask
questions in the mailbag you can hang
out with us during the State of the
Union that will be broadcast for
everybody to see but you know we we give
special care to the daily water members
but forget all of that none of that
matters this is what matters guys
the leftist here's tumblr this is what
matters you need to protect yourself
forget the natural environment can be a
very scary place and regardless of
whether Al Gore is right or not we are
all headed for massive flooding either
because Democrats lost the government
shutdown or because the polar icecaps or
something are gonna melt make sure you
protect yourself and your family with
the leftist here's tumblr this is the
only APA approved vessel it's you're
radioactive leftist tears so you're
gonna have them hot or cold always salty
and delicious make sure to go to daily
wired.com right now we'll be right back
[Music]
gentlemen thank you for being here
Barney the Dinosaur
now runs a tantric sex ring isn't that
just the perfect symbol for our
generation what in childhood was soft
cushioned saccharine shallow has grown
up to become a sexually decadent trans
reptile that's it that's our generation
baby the actor who played Barney the
Dinosaur for ten years David Joyner has
since 2004 run a tantric sex business
where he treats about 30 clients whom he
refers to his goddesses let's take a
look at some footage from that new
business
[Music]
lead with the great
[Music]
the kiss from me
[Music]
yuck there's there's a lot of continuity
there at least Italy is clearly formed a
career himself so okay I don't I don't
really want to talk about Barney I do
want to talk about sex there are there
are not great numbers on this but there
are lots of cultural indicators that
Millennials are both less monogamous and
that they have less sex one study showed
Millennials having significantly less
sex than Gen Xers that said Millennials
watch a ton of porn pornhub.com which is
just one porn site reported an audience
that watched 4.4 billion with a B hours
of pornography in 2015 with 60% of its
audience comprising Millennials Jacob
what does all of this say about
Millennials hooked on porn bizarrely
open attitudes toward sex and yet not
having very much of it to me it shows
that they're buying the feminist
narrative about what sex means because
as far as third wave feminists are
concerned you know women are just they
see sex the same way as men but that's
not true and no matter they but they
keep the feminists keep pushing these
oddly male values right the whole point
of of becoming an adult is you want to
temper yourself and you want to be a
Mary I just celebrated four years with
my own wife and congratulations she's
clearly a saint yes and and a perfect
ten whereas I am a four but anyway the
whole hope the whole point of this is
they want cheap gratification and even
amazing television shows like that they
push that on to our millennial culture
where should sex is just a cheap thrill
that you get oh and maybe it's a little
extra special if you're married to the
person but not really and I think the
Millennials have just bought into this
yeah you would think that people might
grow up after a while I frequently say
there's a time and a place for
everything in that place is college but
you kind of got to move on Benji you're
a college kid
now obviously college is a little
different thing so don't necessarily
think that your current environment
reflects the real world but do you
foresee the situation getting any better
for Millennials or is our culture going
to just keep all of these trends right
on track
yeah I think it's kind of on track to
keep going I think there's a couple of
reasons one you've got the you know the
super religious folks who kind of push
their views on their kids or whoever and
it kind of pushes people away from those
types of beliefs and then you've got
you've got the feminists who really
pushed the anti religious beliefs on
people and I think that accommodation is
gonna force it into the near future
unless some things change I think you
hit it right on the nail on the head
with when you talked about the instant
gratification I think Millennials are
really looking for that it's just
something that they've kind of been
trained to do I mean I look for instant
gratification in almost anything you
kind of you're kind of expecting it as a
millennial these you've got phones
you've got everything kind of right at
your fingertips and so it's it's made it
a little bit harder to kind of have that
same patience as other generations have
and then I think the the media and both
sides from the far you know far
religious right to the far feminist left
you know I think that they both play a
big role in kind of how Millennials are
being shaped right now that's true I do
I don't disagree with your observation I
do wonder though if there is some reason
to hope only from my own personal
experience on this show every question I
get in a mailbag is about some aspect of
tradition or about Christianity or about
returning to religion and often they're
from Millennials and they're from people
who were raised without any serious
engagement with the eternal questions
and the internal questions about human
nature and our relation to our Creator
and how we got here and how the world
got here and I don't know this I guess
it could be a bubble but I just see it a
little bit I've always lived in pretty
liberal places on the coasts and at
universities and I do wonder if the
smartest people in the world right now
are talking about God and the future
generations are talking about what was
lost when we pretended to ourselves that
God is dead and what is a lot what we
throw away with modernity I don't know
obviously it is the case that religious
parents are going to tell their kids one
thing and the feminists are going to
tell their kids another but I wonder if
maybe the children of the religious will
be less turned off than the children of
the feminists if we haven't hit a snag
in the road
I hope so but that's just that's my
wishful thinking man let's move on to
something much funnier a bunch of
illegal aliens descended on Chuck
Schumer's home last night
chanting if Chuck won't let us dream we
won't let him sleep here it is so first
thing no one's stopping you from
dreaming this is the trouble with you
from essence right you know but also
those people look like they're 30
I thought the dreamers were these cute
little six-year-olds who didn't do
anything wrong and they're really nice
those are just adults those are adults
who haven't figured out their own legal
status in their own immigration
situation Jacob why don't we just round
these people up and deport them they're
clearly in violation of the law they're
boasting about being in violation of the
law they're rubbing our faces in it look
to keeping Chuck Shumer up at night is
almost enough for me to offer them full
amnesty then on a larger point it's so
disrespectful of American law of the
American government of a country that
has been so good to these people given
them free education handouts health care
what why don't we just round up all of
the rabble-rousing ones and send them
back to whatever godforsaken country
they fled from in the first place this
is the question of the hour and I think
that you know the fact that they
protested Chuck Schumer who's been
probably their biggest advocate in the
Senate maybe with a couple of exceptions
but he wasn't even home that night
so obviously that group protesting at
his house weren't the best and brightest
of dreamers but I think that I think
that we should look at it in stages just
to round everyone up they'll just come
right back I think first off we got to
get the border secured and then we can
say okay is this person worth giving a
citizenship is it as a citizenship test
or is this person a criminal deviant
that we should send back either way it's
going to be a struggle as far as policy
goes especially as as long as the media
keep giving them headlines you know
these children that's right the 30 or 40
year old children and on that best and
brightest point the data that we have
what the mainstream meeting would have
you believe is it's all six year olds
with seven degrees from MIT we're really
grateful and left their country and
they're just the most all-around
apple-pie people in the world but the
data we have is that 25 percent of them
are illiterate half of them don't speak
English in the demonstrations like these
we see deep ingratitude and entitlement
from a country that's been very good to
them
Benji if Schumer won't give Trump the
wall and an end to chain migration will
we just let daca expire and start
shipping these people home who is gonna
blink first well I think I'll answer
that question a different way I think
that conservatives need to embrace the
dreamers who are here and doing good
things now there are people who are here
doing bad things but that can be said
about any any population the fact of the
matter is is that a lot of these
dreamers had no control over whether or
not they got here and they're just
trying to live their lives in peace and
I and I don't think that that protesting
group kind of showcases what the entire
population is like so that being said
there is a population like the people
who are protesting Chuck Schumer which I
think that you made a really interesting
point talking about how Chuck Schumer is
kind of the biggest advocate of these
folks and you know when when black lives
matter or the dreamers protests
basically everyone an alienate everyone
that's not going to get anything
beneficial done and it's fairly
frustrating and it makes their case look
a lot weaker and I think that that's
unfortunate because there are a lot of
good dreamers here who didn't have a
choice to come here and should you know
should be given the opportunity to
succeed and be successful and it's not
their fault that they're here so I think
that conservatives need to differentiate
and this is something that Republican
congressman the congresswoman said the
other day was that you have to
differentiate between the dreamers who
could be very good people who had no
intention of coming here whatsoever and
are just trying to live their lives and
the illegal aliens who are crossing the
border I think if there's an important
distinction there and it's you shouldn't
want them in on both I worry that it's a
distinction without a difference because
they use this term they use the most
loaded term imaginable dreamer what on
earth does that does dreaming have to do
with
the essence of this issue which is
illegal aliens resident illegal people
what what does that have to do this they
seem to be ossified in time as Victor
Davis Hanson wrote eloquently a couple
days ago so we're talking about a group
of people from only this period to this
period who were brought over below the
age of eighteen now some of these people
are almost 40 years old as I had
mentioned earlier half of them don't
speak English a quarter of them are
illiterate Oh does the category of the
dreamer as the Democrats call I will not
use that terminology because it's such a
deceptive insidious euphemism but of
these this category of people the daca
people the Democrats admitted this in a
memorandum two weeks ago that they're
relying on these people for their
electoral strategy because they know
that if they're granted amnesty they
will trend overwhelmingly to vote for
Democrats so it should Republicans
embrace a group of people who don't
share a lot of as a category don't hold
together very coherent lis and who you
know don't appear to have any advantages
over other immigrant groups or other
immigrant groups from Latin America who
have come here illegally and to are
gonna legalize a million new Democrat
voters I just don't see what the
advantages for the Republican Party to
say yes we need to grant amnesty to them
even the vast majority of the country
doesn't want to give them amnesty and
56% of Democrats don't even want to give
them amnesty I think this is a total a
total game being played by Democrats
they're trying to fool us and I wouldn't
do it at all I'm more than happy to keep
people in the country who are who will
benefit the country and who really are
little children or really don't have any
means to support themselves but some 40
year old who's out there screaming at
Chuck Schumer because we haven't given
him enough absolutely not send those
people back especially and this is the
most important thing if they're going to
vote for Democrats if the so called if
the daca people will agree to vote for
Republicans for 25 consecutive elections
give them blanket amnesty I'm all-in I
think we've reached a grand compromise
though I think the Republicans just just
speaking as a conservative have really
dropped the ball on outreach to latina
families because they have this fake
perception by the fake news media that
oh the Republican Party is the party of
old white men but that's not true
anymore but Republicans have been very
bad at sending out that messaging
because really if you talk to Latin
American families they have a lot of
values like they are pro-life they are
pro marriage they they are hardworking
people who have good worth work ethics
and they would and they can and will
benefit society so I think that if the
dreamers are daca or daca recipients as
you call them if they were to change and
switch sides and say hey we're not going
to vote for Democrats we're gonna vote
for Republicans and we're going to show
you how we can be a benefit to American
society I think that I think that they
could see a turnaround as far as as far
as that goes but I think that
Republicans need to be better at
messaging to that particular community
sure they work hard and go to church so
hopefully it won't be hard to get them
to agree to vote for Republicans for 25
consecutive elections Benji did you have
a final point on this yeah I don't know
if it's even a political issue and I
don't really care if they vote Democrat
or Republican to me it's a human issue
to me it's not political at all it takes
as the affairs of men politics as
Aristotle defines it it's how men
interact with one another in cities to
me I care more about these people's
lives than I care about who they vote
for but I think it's up to Republicans
to reach these people through our
ideologies that can click with their
personalities and I think that's
incredibly key and I think it's an
important point that was just made that
Republicans need to do a better job of
reaching out to these folks and not
making the differentiation between
dreamers and illegal aliens and also
lumping all the people who you know all
the dreamers into the category of the
protesters outside Chuck Schumer's house
I also just don't think that that's fair
so I think that there's a few key
distinctions to be made there sure
they're all illegal aliens that that is
the but there's no distinction between a
dreamer and an illegal alien but you're
right some of the
illegal aliens are wonderful people who
are patriotic and like America and work
hard and go to church and we should keep
those people especially if they vote
Republican and some people are awful in
their gangsters and they commit crime
and they're a net drag on the population
and they won't assimilate and they won't
learn to read English and they won't
learn to speak English and to lump those
people in with the good patriotic people
who came here through no choice of their
own and who have who love their country
and dedicated to it that we shouldn't
lump those two people together I
absolutely agree I agree on the final
point here speaking of our government
and how we the people relate to it a new
poll conducted by Rasmussen Reports
shows that half of likely u.s. voters
believe a special prosecutor should be
named to investigate whether senior FBI
officials handled the investigation of
Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump in a
legal and unbiased fashion that is a
whopping number Benji do we need to
investigate the FBI
man oh man I I think we actually do
there's just been so many fishy things
going on over there and if there's
nothing to worry about what's the
problem in hiring some investigators
that's the way I look at it if they want
if they weren't acting in a biased
fashion they shouldn't have anything to
worry about in my opinion that's right
and you know those all those text
messages went missing there is a lot of
strange stuff going on at the bureau
Jacob are we at the point now where we
have to investigate the FBI either as a
defensive measure if the FBI really has
been politicized by Democrats or just to
route out corruption generally in the in
the federal government I think it's kind
of ridiculous so we have this Russia
collusion investigation going on and so
now we're gonna have another
investigation to investigate whether
that investigation is okay how about no
we just in all the investigations and
that if there is corruption within the
FBI let's fire those people and if they
are treasonous let's bring them up for
treason that is what we're supposed to
do all these investigations all they do
all they do is create more red tape and
they waste more time no enough is enough
let's in all these useless
investigations and let's root out
corruption where it is it's not fair to
malign all of the FBI there are
fantastic English
absolutely and so we need to be so if
there is corruption within the agency
which there could be there's
there could be corruption anywhere where
there's a little bit of power then let's
root it out but as far as an
investigation into the investigation of
this investigation no that's absolutely
ridiculous but I will say yes we should
investigate Hilary yeah the only one to
keep go away yeah and you know you you
make this point I'm sick of all the
investigations - on principle but if we
are in a position now where a lot of
evidence shows that all of the
investigations into Donald Trump were
intended at the highest levels of the
FBI to subvert a democratic process to
subvert the this presidential election
to undo it to weaken this president to
weaken the choice of the American people
then I think we might have to just flex
our muscles on that and make sure that
we aren't being taken by our for a ride
by our self-appointed benevolent betters
in DC who think they can run the country
better than we can ourselves gentlemen
this has been a lovely discussion what
this is one of my favorite panels we've
had in a while and I never say that
about all-male panels I've never once
said if we don't have Ally or roaming or
Cassie or whoever I don't believe it at
all but this has been great to have you
both here thank you very much
Benjie backer and Jacob arey we'll have
to have you back again that is our show
get your mailbag questions in so that we
can you know just change all of our
lives together in the mailbag tomorrow
and until then I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knoll show come back
tomorrow we'll do it all again
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy Borah senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex zingaro
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina herons
makeup is by Jeshua of era the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for word
publishing 2018